hey poppy here it's Papa John and you're
listening to the h3 podcast go Ethan go
ela welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
previously recorded not live
what's previously recorded what did they
say on late nights weddings not live
they say they say previously recorded
right dan no they say sure or live to
tape live to tape that's what we are
guys it's good to be back here on the h3
podcast sponsored by hymns and
expressvpn today we missed last week and
it feels like we haven't been here in
forever but there's so much to talk
about
you know we've got Papa John calling in
later to discuss all the beautiful
things that Papa John always discusses
lots of drama and instead I'm drowning
in drama it's like sometimes it's like a
drama tsunami you know it's like there's
an earthquake and you're like oh that's
drama but then there's a tsunami that
comes later that's what I'm dealing with
here but before we get into that I do
want to announce something going on on
our Twitter called help ela and Ethan
lazy Phil Aunt Ida's are bored to say
philantropy
plant plant philanthropy that's doesn't
sound right that hard to say
go ahead ela you're saying philanthropy
go ahead gee do you see lo how do you
say it then how do you feel and throw P
right philanthropy no no see it's not
that easy to say here's what we're doing
I'm very excited to announce we've been
doing this now for like nine days I
think we decided we are giving away a
hundred thousand dollars cash of our own
money no strings attached no sponsors
that's just a hundred thousand dollars
from my bank account to yours on Twitter
we are making the tweet every day for
100 days giving away a thousand dollars
every day so a thousand dollars every
day for a hundred days
to two winners 500 apiece all you have
to do is retweet and comment with your
PayPal info the retweet is annoying I
know about all these bots these bots
require some kind of action to draw a
winner from and that's it you don't have
to follow me you don't have to comment
and tag 25 friends and basically we just
want to get cash to people who need it
now you know the unemployment rate is
some is like it's crazy it's over 20%
now it's staggering it's just it's scary
it's gonna continue to get worse too
because big companies are closing now
right because naming Marcus is just the
beginning I think because the way I see
this playing out and I won't talk too
much about coronavirus here but is that
there's gonna be a second wave and it
really is just a matter of how bad the
second wave is but I think there's gonna
be another stay at home order and even
if there isn't people are not going to
want to go out in public so I think
shopping malls I think movie theaters I
think restaurants are gonna continue to
suffer for a long long time and so
anyway we wanted to help in whatever way
we could and so the best way we could
think is just to send out cash to my
dogs on twitter so hit me up on twitter
and just yeah to enter everyday just
just respond to my tweets I do it every
day at 12 o'clock and then twelve
o'clock the next day we pick the winners
now here's where it gets cool we're
gonna make a quick note about it I just
want to emphasize share your paypal dot
me link not your email
don't don't post your your public paypal
email because people might try and scam
you right thank you Dan now
Brendon Greene the creator of pub G hit
me up was like y'all want to give 50
grand I said awesome so we have a
hundred fifty grand now so that means we
get three winners a day and we may have
should I announce what I know now or is
that well we shot our call with Papa but
you guys will hear it
Papa John donated $100,000 what can I
can't contain it so now so now we're up
to a quarter million dollars in the help
fund and that's five winners am i doing
yeah five winners every day that's $500
apiece that's $2,500 every day you guys
exciting stuff so make sure to follow me
or you don't have to follow me listen
yeah I'm just saying watch my Twitter
okay at 12 o'clock that's what these
raffles go out okay
promoting our site don't care if you
follow me on Twitter just way for us to
literally hand you money we just found
this to be these take my money take my
money you take my money because people
have criticized that aspect of our
donation but Chris well we found people
will pretty much criticize anything I
even saw people a couple comments of
people saying that the app that we're
using to randomly draw write doesn't
work and it only selects from the
hundred most recent people yes I'm the
one doing the drawing I can tell you
right now that's complete [ __ ] I
don't know where that's coming from
you could I'm able to see you know where
the winners are being drawn from and
it's not just the 100 most recent so I'm
not sure well tell you why because from
if people actually believe that or if
they're just trying to troll you but
when I was doing recently for this all
the free [ __ ] is like and actually even
some of the paid stuff is limited to the
last thousand tweets alright and so I
went and found this premium service
which actually is like what are we
spending like $100 a month or something
it's pretty pricey yeah but anyway they
this is the only one I found and it is
expensive that can actually do a raffle
with that many people so and yes it does
it's not it's not just the last whatever
amount of people yeah every manually
verified that I've gone and looked when
the winners responded and you know
there's people that have one that
responded within the first hour of you
posting it so it is totally legit it's a
hundred percent all good and
and it's great I'm really happy with it
it seems like we've already helped a lot
of people yeah it's actually a really
touching when you look at all the
comments like then showed me I didn't
even realize at first but some people
have been just commenting their story of
you know why they need money and what's
happening with them and then some random
really nice people will give them like
hey here's $20 for me just right it's so
cool nice wholesome the whole thing
every day I agree it's been a it's been
a very great thing and we're only in day
9 so there's still full 90 days left and
now there's five gonna be five winners a
day it's out of control
outrageous but thoughts anyway so that's
that that's really exciting I also want
to say that there's a couple items on
today fresh real fast let's see it's
everything so slow here because of the
co vid but we're gonna start some stuff
going in but we got some t-shirts we got
some bucket hats we got some belts we
got some shirts alright that's that
Teddy first man look like there's not a
lot going on but we are working really
hard on Teddy fresh lots of exciting
stuff welcome preach I think around June
is when things will start to finally
release preach it and then it's gonna
never stop including spongebob restock
and new designs in July okay some
ordinary gamer was the first drama now
as you guys know I have been the subject
of many videos in the past several years
people do not like Ethan Ethan is a
hypocrite he is a greedy he stopped
making h3 videos because he is lazy and
he only wants to make money on the money
money money I love money
that's what so anyway yeah you guys have
heard all that some ordinary gamers is a
guy who made this video about me saying
that I was a hypocrite because I
donation shame Jeff Bezos which didn't
happen which is funny things just didn't
happen and
this video really upset me because like
people would take are always cutting
clips from the podcast and making videos
about it but this is the one of these
times where he he makes this assertion
that I donation sham Jeff Bezos and then
he goes on to expand about how that
makes me Saul this like a hypocrite and
the whole premise of it is not only
something that never happened it's
something that he never even sites or
shows in his video and yet everybody's
taking it for granted which to me was
just so I was like wow this is so [ __ ]
up like people hate me this much that
they're willing to just accept whatever
is said about me without any evidence at
all and then so I tweeted at him and I
says yo just so you know very politely
really I said just so you know the
comments I made about Jeff Bezos were
like 15 days before he donated a hundred
million dollars so I couldn't have
donation shamed him and in response to
those tweets he made and response to our
charity he made a second video taking
credit for my $100 $100 donation being
like oh I wonder why that happened and
further saying you know I did Ethan
didn't donation shame Jeff Bezos but
it's hard to give him credit because
he's oh this is to quote him he's always
punching around billionaires cuz I
really dude so it's my fault you got
that wrong cuz I'm making fun of
billionaires you know billionaires the
the most disenfranchised a group of
people in America by the way let's all
[ __ ] let's all smile in the world
yeah that's true that is true Chile I
love the whole premise of sticking of
like working people sticking their necks
out well it's it's also funny because we
actually we talk about it a lot in both
aspects we've also been on the side of
saying that you know they should exist
versus like we had this all whole
argument when people were saying
billionaires
exactly you guys maybe I'm wait harsher
on them than you guys right
you know defended the idea of people
having that much money but that that is
so frustrating because I couldn't
possibly pack that detail of our
argument into the video yes so much but
for but you guys know that like only
like a month ago I was talking about how
Jeff Bezos created amaz my opinion is
that you know I obviously I obviously
it's complicated right Jeff Bezos is a
guy who created Amazon that
revolutionized the entire world he's
wealthy beyond imagination and so I said
you know the guy he does he he earned it
her so to speak whatever you want to say
and so so people were upset first of all
that I was a defending billionaires and
then you know a month later I'm on blast
for donations shaming Jeff Bezos a lot
of people which I didn't do obviously
this whole concepts very complicated and
frankly you guys I don't I'm out here
these aren't well formulated thoughts
I'm often times talking off the cuff
that's the nature of a podcast right I'm
just here kind of thinking and talking
and sometimes one thing I say might
contradict another thing I say because
because maybe it did make me think about
this like because I think a lot of
people use to see us only in our highly
edited videos because when we make our
videos on h3 you know we think about it
ahead of time we have some kind of
preparation to what we're gonna say and
then after recording there's a lot of
editing so if there was a weird take of
something you cut it out you leave the
good one you know if you didn't say
something right you cut that out but I
think for a lot of people who don't
necessarily follow us all the time
seeing us like just as a hard transition
go from those edited videos to this
podcast that is so unedited it's just
two hours of us saying anything just
talking we don't plan like what I'm
saying right now I didn't think about
this point I'm just making it right now
yeah I think for them it's a hard
transition to see you've this versus
this and I think that's a lot of times
were
those kind of videos come from like
right and and then when you watch a lot
of the criticism videos they're like
central thesis is like they have to stop
the podcast people hate the puck they
hate that we make money from it people
hate that I'm saying things they
disagree with people don't like I think
a lot of it comes from political stuff
too I think like I think that in a
certain point of my career I was making
a lot of videos about social justice
warriors and feminists and all this [ __ ]
and I think that I attracted quite a bit
of more conservative leaning audience
there the truth is anyone that Falls his
podcast or knows I'm I'm definitely a
Democrat and I'm definitely extremely
liberal in all of my personal doctrine
socially and and economically so so like
he made a comment his video like oh
you're I cuz I said we're doing this
charity and I intentionally made it
under $500 so you don't have to report
to the IRS just cash in your pocket
that's the tax law and it was oh don't
tell your buddy Bernie Sanders as if
that's some kind of a slam on me that
I'm like oh you like Bernie Sanders yeah
your body Bernie Sanders it's like so I
think a lot of people see me as I'm
trying to think of the best way to say
this but they see me as I'm not I'm not
one of them they thought I was one of
them and I'm not I'm a Trojan horse even
I'm worse and so I think a lot of I
think a lot of this stuff it comes down
to to politics they think that I may be
a hypocrite
they hate who they see me as here which
is not a feminist hating red pillar I'm
just not I'm a coastal elite bro I'm a
[ __ ] rich coastal elitist
you know that's who I am thrown throw
[Music]
totally if I given the opportunity to
sing and imagine I would if they if
if gal gadot asked me to do a verse and
imagined I would have totally done it
let me just put it that way imagine all
the people oh I would have totally done
it that's what a Costa Lolita I am
speaking of making money on the podcast
we're out 15 minutes if you owe my odd
cast thank you damn nice segue hold on
to that thought guys because today we
are sponsored by expressvpn we all know
expressvpn protects your privacy and
security online right but here's
something you may not know you can also
use Express VPN to unlock movies and
shows that are only available in other
countries and boy do I wish I had this
when we were living in Israel I think we
talked about this last time but man oh
man now that so many you know that I
heard that they've got all these
Miyazaki films but it's only unlike
Japan Netflix bro I needed I need I need
to hook up my Japan IP with expressvpn
so this whole week I've been using
expressvpn to binge Doctor Who on UK
Netflix actually what I need to be doing
is using my expressvpn to binge Miyazaki
films Japan Netflix it's so simple to do
i fire up expressvpn app change my
location to the UK refresh refresh
Netflix and boom pesto bingo bingo
that's all expressvpn hide your IP
address and let you control where you
want sites to think you're located you
can choose from almost 100 different
countries so just think about all the
Netflix libraries you can go through do
you love anime use Express VPN to access
Japanese Netflix and be spirited away
Miyazaki reference everybody but it's
not just Netflix expressvpn works with
any streaming service hulu BBC iPlayer
YouTube you name it goddangit
there are hundreds of VPNs out there but
the reason I use Express VPN to watch
shows is because it's ridiculously fast
there's never any buffering or lag and
you can stream an HD no problem at all
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices
phones media consoles Smart TVs and more
so you can watch what you want on a
personal device or on the big screen
whatever you wherever you are so visit
my special link right now expressvpn
comm / h3 you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free support
the show watch what you want and protect
yourself with expressvpn that's Express
VPN comm / work thank you very much to
our sponsor and so anyway we're talking
about that via so I responded I really
went into the into some kind of crazy
video making frenzy and we made our
longest video ever 37 minutes and
response and I there was just so much to
unpack I mean the guy he takes every
opportunity to paint me in the worst
possible light and everything he says is
wrong he goes Ethan why don't you Oh
Ethan the owner of teddy fresh why
aren't you making n95 respirator masks
and then he goes the death toll is
getting pretty [ __ ] high then I'm
like dude I'm not killing people you're
making it sound like I'm feeling yeah
I'm like well I cannot make n95
respirator masks I can't just go do that
it's very complicated there's only like
a handful of manufacturers in the world
that can do like 3m you know 3m Dalek
huge like there's there's literally a
handful of companies that can do that in
the entire world and just sit there and
just throw all this [ __ ] at me you know
very upsetting and so me actually
donation ashamed us yeah which was very
sad it did hurt my feelings he goes he
goes Ethan I could do the same thing you
do like you only donated a $1,000 to
team trees but I'm not gonna do that but
he did do that and I did it so I talked
about this at length in our video but it
was um it just it felt so bad that like
this video was going viral he made and
you read through the comments and
everybody's just convinced that somehow
I'm like the worst person that has ever
lived and
I'm really I realized this at 8 is very
chauvinistic
because all the hate is only going
towards you and I got none of it nice I
wish I wish I could do with a little
chauvinism well I was well I don't know
I was here - teddy fresh where where am
I in the conversation
I think I write and I and I'll tell you
why I think people do that they are
always avoiding criticizing you because
I'm the easy target and people are more
protective of you so they know if they
go after you and this has happened
before when people go after you that
that people are not receptive to that
criticism because they see me as the
problematic person and you're just
trying to clean up my mess but you're
right they are well you're right why
aren't you Allah making but that's a
little bit so monistic way to look at it
going to think like I'm just here
cleaning up your mess yeah it's no we
blend everything together whatever
you're saying saying I usually agree
with him you know unless I say otherwise
which I normally will say on the podcast
you know sometimes we disagree but I
just always find it funny like not
always I will say in your defense like
for example the whole PewDiePie fiasco
with the n-word and the drunken rants
and all that and we're not here right
you were actually there tending to your
father who's dying
yeah to make things worse so it's not it
is not always your fault not always but
anyway so that was happening and I
honestly during that whole week I had
such tension anxiety I felt like I was
gonna puke all the time because I was
just I was so upset about it
mother-fricker mother freaking crap
mushrik also it was the timing was very
annoying because we were planning a
donation and we have been thinking about
it for a long time we weren't sure what
we wanted to do like you guys watch the
podcast know that we have done those
charity streams a few times and that was
initially our first idea but
it didn't feel the same like we just
felt we just wanted it to go directly to
people and not to some charity fund that
you know it's the game philosophy I
again was curious yes it was very much
inspired by yang well the whole
atmosphere right now was like the
government sending people checks people
are talking about ubi so it's very much
inspired by the movement of the time and
and yeah you know it's much easier just
to give money to a and we never did
share this much when you we wanted to do
something big so but I don't want it to
think about it you know and I know you
guys think we're rich I know everyone
thinks we're rich and like and okay
we're rich $100,000 a [ __ ] lot of
money that hurts my bank account trust
me no but it doesn't hurt isn't it more
isn't it more um isn't it more admirable
if it's painful every time right because
if it feels good then you're like hey
everybody take my money I'm feeling
happy it hurts me every time I give that
money out and that's what makes it
beautiful
so it doesn't hurt I'm kidding I'm
kidding
whether it's a lot of money is my point
it's a lot of money yeah it's a hundred
thousand [ __ ] dollars it's a lot of
bubblegum
Thank You Zac every times that plays a
sound bite it switches to him it's
awesome
go ahead Zack play something anyway yes
I was I was very upset by that and I
honestly just had to to respond so
that's on our YouTube channel
everybody loves Ethan it's up there so
please enjoy that but I will say that oh
great now Fredo your bark is not high
determinating is more intimidating
shredder Alfredo's Berg
yes shredders hurts more will be
cuddling and he hears something and
it'll just barks trade into over here
yeah it's so painful I think he's a
fraud damaged my hearing crazy astroturf
he did make an apology but I will say
after we made ours he here all open it
up we can we can watch a bit of it but
he basically made a sincere apology he's
like yo I was wrong I'm removing both my
videos and straight-up apologizing to
Ethan you know so there you have it
I own apology 100% ladies and gentlemen
sorry for the off-the-cuff video quality
out there it's it's just it's it's an
apology that I have to pretty much get
out 100% because I kind of want to make
this video before sort of like any other
you know hundred like many channels pick
this [ __ ] up and covered it because the
reality of it is I do an apology and the
last thing I want to see is people fight
for me when I'm clearly in the wrong now
I made two videos one of them was the
Hippocrates incline that's it I mean
clearly a heartfelt sincere yeah I won't
say anything I mean you know what you
know what the the problem with this guy
for me is that he actually seems like a
decent guy he seems like a dude I would
like and there's so many comments on
your response video to him saying this
is really hard to see because I like
both of these guys but obviously he's in
the wrong here but it does seem like
there's quite a bit of overlap between
the audiences so yeah I mean it is
unfortunate that uh you know it's not
like that Dancing with Logan Paul or
something where there's almost no
overlap between the the audience bases
hit the video he made about me kind of
reminds me of when I made he reminds me
of myself
you know I I've made that same mistake
that he has where I like for example
looking back at like the Wall Street
Journal where I kind
made a video too hastily got it wrong
and then had to retract and it's like
the first video is so explosive and it's
so compelling but it's wrong you know
and so I've done this that's that's kind
of where I have a level of empathy for
him I've done this myself so that's it I
mean I really got no beef with this guy
I responded he apologized and that's it
it's a simple matter no that's it
there's really nothing else to say yeah
I appreciate it so that was that you
know the beef is squashed clearly the
drama is over with him but isn't it
isn't it so does it what do you think
about the fact that the video we made
has 65,000 dislikes I mean that's three
hundred and seven thousand likes at this
moment but there's still 65,000 people
who watched a video where I can clearly
materially defending myself yeah it's
weird I don't know don't like Age 3 you
know the first hour we put it up it had
like 50% dislike like his fans were
ready they were on the trigger and I was
like what is going on and I thought I
thought I was in bizarro world
it's 37 minutes though so it took it
takes a minute to get your teeth into it
anyway everyone loves Ethan we all know
that to be true right so moving on then
at the same time I was working on this
video Trisha
yes Trisha Paytas the one and only puts
out a video I was like man this is way
too much for me [ __ ] she puts out a
video called h3 ruined my relationship
out of control I cannot believe what
this [ __ ] has turned into a Trisha can
you believe no I can't believe it I keep
remembering the last time we saw her I
was sitting next to her in our podcast
room
everything was nice she wanted to [ __ ]
us I was a 10 back
that you wanted a truffle um throuple
yeah you said trouble it's my accent say
throuple sorrowful oh you huh yeah you
can't do that the a that was good say
throuple but it feels weird let's try it
just write her up Paul is that like when
I'm speaking here when I go and it will
go safe I'm not gonna interesting even
after all this time you can't or it
still feels weird yeah well just
derailed that point you were making you
were saying you were sitting next to her
and it was all good it was all good we
had a good vibe going we complemented
each other she loved us she was saying
we're her new best friends I don't get
it and since then we never talked so I
don't even know what the hell well she
she started [ __ ] your brother
straight up that's what happened and
it's just she goes on and she says
honestly her video is so [ __ ] long
dude she needs to editor bro 33 minutes
I mean dude come on
I know I just said I made it 37 minute
video but I really feel like she's lost
the plot here like this is like a three
minute video because she she basically
says that we are pressuring Moses to
break up with her which really is not
the pic my problem with this thing in
the beginning was a clearly vocalize
here is that I don't know what is
happening all I ever saw was that all
the sudden Moses's and all of her
pictures and videos and I'm like what
also we've said to both of them I
brought a photos at the show so he also
knows but to Tricia we told her what
happened last time with a bachelor we
talked about it on the show and we said
how there was a wild card and that ended
the show so we said whatever happens
just tell us
right but that makes the see yeah that's
true but then I haven't heard I don't
care about the show right no finds what
I'm saying like we just never never even
heard anything well yeah all I saw was a
them in a picture together and what what
really what bothers me is that the word
colliding your brothers someone that
were very closest that we see all the
time and Trisha is one of the subjects
of our pop one the like we're having
like a huge Trisha arc right now and so
for these worlds to collide I mean it's
it's ILA's brother do you understand how
weird that is this girl that were old
it's like I've had beef with Trisha and
now all of a sudden her brother isn't is
like her best friend I mean this is just
so strange anyone who watches Seinfeld
knows the words should not collide
anyways someone I saw this response on
her YouTube video that I thought was
great they says oh and then of course
keemstar the ever truth pursuer of truth
he like he's so desperate to [ __ ] on me
he'll goes he even tweets out her video
in defense of Trisha oh he's such as I
forget what he said he goes oh yeah he's
such a snake this is totally something
he would do it's like bro when you find
yourself tweeting in defense of Trisha
saying I ruined her relationship that's
rock bottom desperation
King star will never miss an opportunity
to swing at me and and that's fine
anyway they say post they says she posts
a picture with him posts about how much
sex they're having gets obsessed with
his religion right because he made like
uh all these Passover videos and
hebrew-speaking videos post videos
teaching people Hebrew post videos
eating sacred Jewish food and a messy
and uneducated way post really rude
things about the dudes brother-in-law on
Twitter dude can't even take a [ __ ]
without her following him around to most
people that would scream red flag and
make them run for the hills but no it
was h3 that ruined your affair okay girl
keep it up out of you that's a great
point it was a comment on our video but
what I said is like I you don't need any
help
ruining relationships from me maybe that
was me but I was a little annoyed on top
of everything here we have just heads up
where
we're at the 33 minute mark actually one
more sponsor read we are sponsored and
supported today by hands hems hemp hemp
hemp hemp I listen you've heard us
talking about hands and how they're
helping guys look their best and if you
haven't yet it's time to see what
they're all about 66% of men start to
lose their hair by age 35 and once
you've noticed your hair is thinning it
can be too late is that hair line slowly
starting to move backwards do you have
any bald spots yet well guys the best
way to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some dying why do you guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine and science here's the
solution guys for hems comm
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men it's time to
write a new chapter folks one in which
you have beautiful luscious hair hims is
helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat hair
loss no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements folks this is the
real stuff prescription solutions backed
by science hims was created by a guy who
knows that sums men health conversations
are easier online that in-person that
means no more awkward in-person doctor
visits or long pharmacy lines connects
you with real doctors which could save
you hours it's completely confidential
and discreet all you have to do is
answer a few quick questions a doctor
will review and they will determine if
it's right for you boom right now my
listeners can get started with their
first month for free go to for hanscom's
slash h3 that's for him calm slash h3
disclaimer prescription requires an
online consultation with a physician who
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate offer valid only if
prescribed three months of minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information remember
guys for hams com / h3 keep that
beautiful hair in your head what were we
talking about oh yeah we had this insane
Twitter beef it was like non-stop and I
was just feeling so bad about this
oh yeah she erased this one to it which
was a shame because my response was so
good she said something about how she
wanted to [ __ ] me in Hilo for only fans
and I said I would rather put my dick
and a wood chipper and she removed the
she removed it
and so we were beefing on Twitter it's a
lot I don't have it all in a folder but
lots of back-and-forth she says I hate
she goes I absolutely hate Ethan like
crazy like she lost her mom you know
crazy
thank you feels like yeah you go Trisha
and like the day before he's like saying
awful things about her but then all of a
sudden yeah with him ruin my
relationship
you go girl I've always been a huge fan
you only speak the truth she said and
then today or was it yesterday I thought
if we go I don't look III don't know
what to say at this point I'm just gonna
cold my tongue I'm not gonna think but
then now she he pops up in her new video
called my special guest is water and by
the way is this social distancing EULA
well if they've already [ __ ] then I
guess what does it matter
yeah I mean I'm I don't know we we're
not seeing any they [ __ ] are you
saying you don't know I don't know if
this qualifies as quarantine for me but
they had sex already yeah yeah they're
in the as the New York naked but no
Reming so then they they're eating
cheese sticks together this just pops up
on my feet and I got to tell you no word
from Moses last I heard they weren't
hanging out and look I'm not upset I'm
just find it bizarre I mean can you keep
that for me that this is so [ __ ]
bizarre that my brother-in-law Sheila's
brother is now in a Trisha Paytas video
doing Mook bangs and I didn't even know
I don't even know that they're hanging
up
I mean guys this is this is bizarre you
cannot take that from me all I can say
is just really the words should never
collide I can't I did not watch this
video I am NOT I'm just out I said are
you boycott everything I'm out this is
not content for me I'm not the tart I'm
not the target audience for this month
then it's just maybe I asked to well you
probably might be someone they're eating
I want that [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie
can I say something actually that's
probably gonna sell Trisha more those
cheese dogs are not that good Ian
brought him for us once and they're kind
of over overrated how do you think she
you know I might get a bit rash to be
fair
cuz I thought well there but it would
have been way better if you got it right
out of the oven because he had to drive
over and like my you know it was like 45
minutes later at that point well the
problem that threw me for a loop is that
they coat it in sugar and I was like
what I don't want sugar all my deep
fried cheese it's not sweet and savory
kind of thing I wasn't like huge on it
either but I would want to try it fresh
out of the oven cuz with anything like
melted like think about mozzarella
sticks once it's like coagulated a
little bit and it sat there for a while
it's not as good so I'm with a case of
these things okay we'll get some more
tequila but I just imagine I mean can
you just imagine how strange this is
what am I supposed to think about your
brother or not does he owe us to tell us
when they're hanging out or I mean at
this point I mean am I not supposed to
be shocked this I just don't get it like
what am I so am I supposed to react to
this I mean really doesn't somebody
guide me I don't know man
that is the weirdest element of all this
is how I mean you guys obviously know
him way better than me and I don't know
Moses that well but from the outside
looking in it's bizarre how
yeah ambiguous about it he's being like
I with the amount of time that you guys
talk to him and everything I would've
imagined that he would have been more
forthcoming with yes going on but he's
he's an enigma I don't know it's nice I
couldn't agree more
I don't want to say I mean I can't say
that I'm surprised because my brother
can be ambiguous like that I guess it's
just that I was never involved on that
side of his life you know it's like I
always see him from here from his sister
it's just that and he always follows our
channel and he watches every video and
every podcast so it's weird because
we're always able to talk to him we
always talk about whatever we just
posted but now that it's like we're
going back together from the other side
just getting well listen I love you
brother I love a great guy he's done a
lot for us I don't know I don't I just
gonna bite my tongue I guess I have a
lot to say I'm not going to but he has
his own channel and if this is helping
him also like rich you know new audience
then I'm happy for him cuz channel water
that's the name of his channel channel
water the comments on that video of them
in the car was so funny to cuz um I
guess you know but as this was talking
like philosophy or something at one
point and she's just like scarfing down
these she's talk now I wanted to ask it
are you aware of the fact that there's
some people that think that this is all
fake yeah it was a good coming at you
for that not so many people this kind of
a part of the same conversation of
people just literally so like people
have pretty much combed through every
podcast we've ever made and and and and
you know milked every drop pretty much
so now what you're seeing is people just
outright making
shut up okay you've got this some
ordinary gamer saying a donation shame
jeff bezos which never happened and now
there's this and then here's another
video this grow it's called a creep show
art is her channel the video is called
h3 h3 is faking drama with Trisha Paytas
for views and it's gross right now it
ain't big
trust me I wish it was vague I wish it
was but you know what this [ __ ] I'm
dealing with is like [ __ ] you I wish
that [ __ ] was fake look at this tweet
and then people they speak so harshly
look look what she says on Twitter when
she announced it she goes new video
remember when h3 h3 was known for
calling out and making fun of [ __ ]
on YouTube because now they have
resorted to faking drama with Trisha
Paytas for money and clout and how the
mighty have fallen
but lo vapenation a do you feel anything
from doing this with Trisha what clout
well yeah exactly I've got I'm crazy ass
clout
well she hurt her or proof that I'm
faking it is that our content with
Trisha gets more views than average
that's it well that I mean that you
transparent that there's no denying that
you parent Lee said that you love having
her on because it's great content and
people check it out
I mean entertaining is [ __ ] what do you
think I endure
she's insane but it's entertaining
that's why people like it it's crazy
the woman puts alfredo sauce a
purse-snatcher what the [ __ ] that's
that's yeah that's great rating actually
Dan you'll be happy to know that she I
think she used that clip as proof that
I'm that off enter her equation about
how I'm faking it when it comes to the
stuff with Trisha so but trust me my
brother would not fake anything
participating Emma
we're not milking it that much
like I'm barely talking about the fact
that Moses and Trisha are hanging out
now and it's totally out of control
it's not like I'm [ __ ] running some
kind of it's not like I've got a hidden
camera on Moses's [ __ ] nipple or some
[ __ ] the tip of his dick you know what I
mean
I'm like if this was fake I'd be milking
it a lot more but it's just it's
annoying it's just [ __ ] up that people
now are just straight-up like I'm such a
common fulfillment now video have a lot
of views yeah okay I mean I mean it's
not a small amount under 50,000 people
are just willing to accept anything
about me at this point
remember when Ethan used to call out
[ __ ] well now he eats babies but
vape - right
I was like whoa the talk comment on here
this is a common theme I've seen a lot
of talking about how the Kings have
fallen does anybody else find that to
just be the craziest [ __ ] ever like
referring to to you as a as a falling
king yeah I don't like it either I mean
look there's this whole it's just stupid
there's this whole narrative that
because I moved on because I dare to
change and embrace a different type of
content that I am that I've fallen I
mean fell out yeah I mean it's just I
don't want to make [ __ ] I don't want
to make the same [ __ ] that I was five
years ago that's it
I find this more I find this content to
be more dynamic it's more collaborative
it's more interesting it's more in-depth
it's we're just place in our life - and
this is what works for us right now this
is what we feel like make it you know
what people don't want us to make this
content because we make money from it I
find it so funny
it's like YouTube logic like there's
logic that only works on YouTube and if
you ever talk to someone outside of
YouTube they'll be like what like for
example us being successful is somehow a
point against us right now
right right oh they're so out of touch
ever since they became successful
they're just like a point of ridicule
every well now that now that we're
actually likes you know wealthy
everything is now we've now everything
we've done in life is for money
yeah which you knowa know the reason I
mean way of looking at it anyone who
does anything goes to work anywhere does
it for money and also being able to
actually make money off of something you
love doing like your hobbit make that a
profession is a goal for like a lot of
people I don't understand that's
something that I'm proud of that's not
something that I'm ashamed of you should
be because you soul your soul because
you stopped making good videos and you
started making bad videos and when you
start making bad videos you also started
making a lot more money that's pretty
that's a speculation by the way that's
what they say everybody likes to assume
that like we make a hundred thousand
dollars per episode I always see that
get thrown alright just crazy hundred
thousand dollars per episode and now I'm
seeing all these everyone thinks that
we're worth like 25 million and all this
crazy [ __ ] like all these kids busy
counting my money have never heard of a
mortgage but we bought a nine million
dollar house and kids you you understand
what a mortgage is right just because I
I owned a nine million dollar house
doesn't even mean that I'm worth nine
million dollars if anything it if you
got a loan for it it subtracts from me
net worth
yeah well well let's say you got a nine
million dollar house usually a down
payment for something like that would be
like twenty thirty percent you're
looking at two three million bucks down
so you own two to three million dollars
of a nine million dollar house now
obviously that's a lot of money I'm not
saying that I'm not wealthy but all
these kids busy counting my money and
inflating my net worth I have like it's
like dude of course I have a mortgage on
a nine million dollar house what are you
crazy
you know I mean not that rash I'm rich
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna sit here
and deny it
I'm Rich's fuck-boy
there's still something that is so weird
and I feel like just on a personal level
it's still something that is kind of new
to us and it's not really like I don't
know I feel like that's a whole other
topic ya know it's like look we we were
broke our whole life we were almost like
starving at some point Wall Street I
almost had to go back because I couldn't
afford staying and for us we're still
that people you know it's not like all
of a sudden I'm a completely different
person now that we make money I we work
hard for our money and we pay taxes 50%
of what we make we pay taxes so I'm not
gonna sit down and feel bad because
people are like oh you sellout no I'm
proud that the fact that we made it here
and it's hard-earned money that we can
taxes on we work [ __ ] super hard
meant building Teddy fresh into a
successful company wasn't something easy
that we did overnight I mean that's a
lot of work and a lot of energy and a
lot of risks and it's it's not been easy
but it's been something that we're
passionate about we love doing it we're
passionate and so I don't think we even
talked I don't trust rated this is like
that space that I get in whenever I
start looking at any of those like
stupid videos whatever but I think I
think the board comments I think the big
issue here is that we as as muda har the
some ordinary gamers even said in his
original video he goes look I know Ethan
is an easy target and I think that's
what's going on there's a whole economy
for age 3 hate videos for one reason or
another so it's not even that these
creators hate me the per se it's that
they they're taking the angle that they
know works and they're feeding into it
that's exactly what happened with some
ordinary gamer with this whole hypocrite
thing he he knows this video is gonna
get him tremendous views and accolades
and he even says it in the game is video
he goes ladies and gentlemen we've got a
hell of a video for you today because he
knows that this is what the people
want and so I don't think that that guy
even he doesn't care that much about me
being a hypocrite he just wants to make
a video that people know that that will
click and consume because it's just I'm
an easy target because I never respond
to this [ __ ] and if I do what's on the
podcast and and it doesn't have the same
amount of teeth that's why I feel like I
had to make an h3 video in response to
that one and so you know everyone
everyone accepts that I'm now the most
evil dude and I suck and I'm a hypocrite
and I've changed and all these things
and so yeah everybody is very happy and
willing to accept pretty much any
premise about me so there is an
incredible economy of h3 hate videos and
people are just feeding into that I
don't you know what I mean they're just
playing into that and it's like this
crazy echo chamber where it gets worse
and worse and worse still I'm basically
like I'm like Jeffrey Dahmer at this
point like they hear people talk about
me they think that I'm like Epstein or
some [ __ ] when all I did was like mad
worse say some things that they didn't
like you know what I mean and somehow
I'm like [ __ ] Adolf Hitler reanimated
well how am I supposed to feel about
this by the way Trisha Paytas and this
video she made with Moses so I'm gonna
I'm supposed to just let them be right
your brother is hanging out with her
somebody said in a comment this is the
exact inverse of Ethan Ely Ethan is more
talkative and is the one that likes to
eat food whereas eva is thinner and
quiet and he's healthier Trisha is more
talkative and likes to eat she's
basically saying you're you guys I'm
Trisha and you're your brother and
they're so so she responds she says net
in all caps never compare me to that
thing ever again with a hundred
exclamation marks so how am I supposed
to feel it's like do you want do you
want your space do you guys want to do
your own thing or do you want me to talk
about you guys and to your brother I
pose that some question because he's
there hanging out with her like it's all
good but like am I not supposed to
acknowledge comments like this I don't
know and by the way Trisha your [ __ ]
mask has holes in it so what the [ __ ]
are you doing
your corrent your mask
like met is made of mesh I mean that's
so sweet yes oh gods no I
maybe's be dazzles like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
this dumbest thing I've ever seen in my
life
it might be bedazzled because you know
what I think I think that they might be
rhinestones actually yeah it looks like
either way it's probably rhinestones
but let's say it's holes because it's
flares anyway moving on one more topic
here and then we're Papa John's gonna
call in and give us updates on the Papa
verse but I actually ate a bread of just
about 55 minutes in okay perfect
this was so you guys know that we've
been SWAT victim of swatting us well we
moved to this house it happens several
times last week I got a letter from the
Department of Justice was that one on
earth is this and he says this is for
the victims unit and they has a time and
date of a court appearance and the
information about some dude I never
heard of I'm like I'm so confused
and I google the name and look at this
[ __ ] former ODU student pleads gets a
plea deal over neo-nazi groups swatting
calls this is the [ __ ] that
swatted us and by the way is this the
most white trash looking I love that
these guys are neo-nazis like then
masterrace dude Hitler would have
exterminated your ugly ass trust me the
master race was with white supremacist
all looking like there's nothing supreme
about that trust me yeah I mean it is
uncanny that they almost always look
exactly like that is why power reminds
me of the Chappelle white power
the white man is supreme man this guy is
like anyway so this guy's in prison and
actually the details this guy is pretty
prolific career apparently he has
swatted a hundred and thirty people
crazy that's a full-time job hundred
thirty-four people across the country
let's see I mean no surprise that they
actually caught him with so many cases
they probably it's so cool that they can
catch these guys though because they all
think that rings slick because they like
use skimpy ends and Skype and nobody
know but the FBI's like [ __ ] we know
who you are I'm so happy that these kids
are going through they have back doors
to like all things yes things were
secure using Skype prosecutors in the
court filing called it one of the most
far-reaching and prolific swatting
conspiracies known to law enforcement
Shannon calls included in November 2018
bomb threat against a predominantly
african-american church nice in response
to another swelling called last November
against a vape shop how would you do my
big job
yes Ave now I'm pissed come on Dan have
you Dave have you baked at all are you
still off I'm off the bait brother was
that I mean the last well you guys my
date was when we went to Disneyland like
I was waning off at that time and then
that day at Disneyland because I
couldn't really do it there that was
like a push so yeah I mean
how are you doing are you chewing gum or
getting nicotine in any other way
no no I'm Nick Nick free Wow how do you
feel good now sucked quitting but huh
yeah man I mean there have been a few
short periods of time where I wasn't on
nicotine or however you want to phrase
that throughout the years but I mean I
had started smoking cigarettes at like
18 mom and I'm 32 now and so yeah I mean
that's it's a long time while I'm happy
a claim 13 that's not easy to do so
fantastic work to you I'm very happy
thank you thank you don't want you dying
on me you know this coronavirus don't
[ __ ] around with smokers right yeah and
yeah I'm definitely thankful in that
regard I mean I I don't I think the
jury's still somewhat out on the whole
vaping thing I know that there was that
scare last year where people got really
worried but it seemed like it was about
contaminated things or whatever blah
blah blah so you know I don't want to
it's not good for you I don't want to
write it off completely like it's it's
it's horrible you shouldn't do it or
whatever
it did I mean it it ultimately helped me
quit smoking cigarettes which I think
you know I think it's great for that but
I don't think people should pick up
vaping instead of smoking you know what
I mean yeah and I mean especially when
there is a pandemic going around that
attacks people's lungs it just seems
like you should probably try and keep
your lungs in fairly tip-top shape so
now is a good time to kick it if you are
doing it but the job then yeah well
here's where the story gets crazy so
this is this guy and then I got another
letter from the Department of Justice
yesterday I was like what and so I open
it similar thing different name also
what because we've been swatted several
times so I don't know if this was from
us difference incident or if they were
working together but get a load of this
guy okay bro this guy I don't want to
have anything to do with this guy as
Charles Manson face
what do you hear this headline accused
former white supremacist leader who
shared child pornography and is implied
in five murders nationwide yeah this
[ __ ] guy SWAT was involved why the
[ __ ] dude
now that shit's crazy this guy's crazy
the implication is that they are linked
because they were bad at this Adam
Waffen division which is a online
neo-nazi group so the Adam often what
does that mean is that German often is
sort of a reference to the SS right I
think it means they like waffles they
like the muffin top
yeah listen this [ __ ] waffen-ss was you
know the term for that's I don't know I
don't think so i think it's a reference
to that this is why i bought a shotgun
by the way look at this [ __ ]
again what's so great about the white
race look at this guy he's got a very
symmetrical face i won't [ __ ] him i want
to reproduce with him the alleged former
leader of a white supremacist group
accused of threatening journalists and
activists was also involved in sharing
child pornography this guy's that got
the triple threat
mister Denton's arrests in Texas was
part of a national crackdown on the Adam
Waffen division described by prosecutors
and experts as a group of extremists
bent on provoking a violent race war
excellent
isn't that what Charles Manson was doing
to exactly what he did Wow oh and tough
fascinating but I don't want to be what
was the name of the actress Thea's house
they went to I definitely Sharon Tate
I'm not gonna be your Sharon Tate you
[ __ ] this guy's doing them ah
that's not cool they also got another
house to LaBianca which was a
yeah they did like two murders on this
thing night or something like that so
you all think that like it's so fun and
games until you get a letter from the
Department of Justice saying this guy is
cracking down on him cuz I've heard
about this atom often did that group oh
yeah they I mean not like a ton or
anything but I I was definitely aware of
them as being a prominent online
neo-nazi group or whatever just looked
it up it means nuclear weapons in German
attracted the attention of the feds so I
mean I don't know what yeah well they
killed five people apparently yeah
that'll do it because they're more
information I look at you say my
attention to co-conspirators have told
investigators that mr. Denton scans and
sent photos of a 16 year old girl dating
and other white supremacists it's
because of such Fox
she said they also told law enforcement
that Denton was trading child
pornography back and forth with another
individual I had a folder with material
on his computer sick that's nuclear bro
what was the part about the murders was
he he's in jail he's gonna get
coronavirus now it's crazy it's a shitty
time to go to jail somebody got out it
was um oh Michael Cohen got out but our
Kelly and Bill Cosby naughty or avenatti
or whatever trying to do the same I
think because Michael Cohen cooperated
so I think they're tossing him a bone Oh
God he's under house arrest now that's
gonna be so nice to think you're gonna
be in prison and then you're like yeah
you get to just stay at home
but Bilka yeah he's basically free yeah
yeah yeah uh blah blah blah more than
six idiot yeah I'm trying to find the
[ __ ] about the murder oh yeah this was
great in his Adam Waffen chatroom he
went by the nickname rape right
oh my god this guy so dark
he's accused of organizing a threatening
campaign against probe Republic reporter
who had named him and other Adam Waffen
members fake threats were also called in
to probe Republican New York office on
the reporter's name yada yada yada I
don't see the part about murder but it
says in the headline look at this crazy
[ __ ] that he is connected with five
murders so that's fun and exciting times
not really not really at all not at all
and so with that being said let's let's
go ahead and get pop on the phone and
see we'll see what he's got for us so
we'll go to a quick cut and we'll be
right back with your boy Papa John today
we have a very special guest the one and
only Papa John part two back to give us
the pizza updates the pizza secrets the
pizza dirt do we have any pizza dirt
Papa John's beat the pizza grease what
do we got here today in the pizza world
pizza if you're the pizza delivery
business this as good as you get it's a
good time to be selling pizza oh my gosh
I mean you got 310 million people
trapped at home you got cheese at an
all-time low at a dollar a pound fuels
low yummy this is as good as it gets if
you're in the pizza business I mean you
could sell [ __ ] on a stick and some are
so Papa you are not really in the pizza
business that much anymore you you last
after your last appearance you sold a
lot of Papa John's stock to the tune of
what was it like a hundred million or
something by my basics like that and so
that I think you know if you right now
things are really good so I think it's
maybe a good time to really look its own
some stock as long as people are
confined I think sales and the pizza
deliver business or continue to go up
which is a good thing when you're
selling stock because you want things to
go up
the question is when the restraints
lesson and it gets a less restrictive
and people start guiding out you know
that curve for pizzas probably going to
start going down but what's inevitable
short term is the price of cheese cannot
be sustainable in a dollar path
I think the Farmers dairy farmers give
or take the size of the farm break-even
about a buck 65 a buck seventy worth a
dollar if you look at the chart real
quickly you see the job right the fees
it takes and give you an idea Papa
John's uses about two and half million
pounds a week so $1 pounds is what two
and evvamean a week which is three
hundred fifty thousand bucks a day a
staggering amount of money but it goes
up as the farmers have more head of
cattle demand exceeds supply and the
price goes up
the problem with cheese is milk is
perishable within you know three days so
once that curve goes down then the dairy
cattle go to the slaughterhouse become
hamburger and then you've got a supply
and demand so this this will not go back
up slow this will jump back up to 250
300 pounds so right now it's the
gettin's good if you're in the pizza
delivery business but once that's it the
sales start trending down which they
will when they release the restrictions
and cheese soars to pick the number to
253 three dollars a pound because
historically this has never happened
then that's probably when you want a
short Papa John's stop when she starts
or enough because our model breaks about
$2 a pound to 20 pound franchisees don't
make any money and this will jump back
up rather quickly Pablo why is the
cheese value so low supply and demand
you know cheese is used to a market
demand of say X hundred million pounds a
week and when the restaurants aren't
open you have a product that's
perishable in three days so you have
excess supply and demand goes down when
demand goes down then the price goes
down
the problem is even in the short-term
the dairy farmers can't survive at a
dollar twenty pounds Allen 30 much less
a dollar so was it when this trend
reverses it will spike way up in a hurry
so it spike down faster than it ever has
in the history of cheese it'll spike up
faster than the history of cheese and
remember 35 40 percent of the cost of
the pizza is cheese hmm there you have
it the Papa in sight now tell me what is
your favorite cheese I'm just curious
oh come on you know what the answer is
well when I was making pizzas at Greeks
pizzeria Montse we used a little bit of
a provolone and monster oh but it's got
to be mozzarella right oh it's gotta be
mozzarella yeah Nick's the monster of
the provolone or whatever you always mix
it with mozzarella six cheese blend of
Papa John's it had six other cheeses or
had five other cheeses plus mozzarella
so yeah you want to blend it with
mozzarella
you got to otherwise you're not even
making a pizza now by by as I understand
it we have well you are involved in some
kind of charity for Kovan 19 you've got
some updates regarding Richie aka Judas
from the biblical times and I'd love to
hear about both of those topics let's
take the easy one the fun one yeah I
love entrepreneurs I love the small
business owners I looked at Papa John's
not as 5,000 stores but it's one store
5,000 times Papa John's is a family of
small businesses and I like that
and so the two things I really enjoy are
the frontline team members at Papa
John's franchisees the employees etc and
also the frontline team members and
frontline defense that we have with
Corona 19 so the what I'm doing we did
the churches and all the local charities
we we fed the frontline defenders up in
lesson Kentucky with wild health and the
castle but today we announced we're
going to give a million dollars for
small
businesses which is what I love to help
small businesses their employees and
then continue with the frontline
defenders so I get to do the frontline
defenders and I also get to do the
employees and then I get to help out
with guidance with small business in
fact we have a site that has merchandise
this is just some of it right here on
your t-shirts papa
yeah topple blessed shirts coming out
whoa whoa we're gonna have to have an IP
discussion about that mugs bandanas
masks etc and every every merchandise
piece merchandise that folks buy on our
support network and our merchandising
network imagine dollar for dollars with
a million dollars so we can take that
million dollars and parlay it into too
many pretty quickly make an impact I
hear you are doing something pretty
special
we are well thank yes thank you for yes
the setup there we are giving away a
hundred thousand dollars on Twitter to
basically its we like to think of it as
the h3 stimulus but it's called help and
basically we just we're just giving away
we set aside a hundred thousand dollars
we're doing it for a hundred days a
thousand dollars a day and and and some
some other generous soul donated fifty
thousand so now we've got 150 thousand
dollars in this for this campaign and so
there's three winners every day for a
hundred days and each person gets 500
bucks so you know just trying to get
people money out there to help people
with groceries internet bill utilities
you know cash in hand immediately to
help people when they need it you know
well that's awesome
I'll tell you what I'll do I'll match a
hundred thousand your hundred thousand
if when we do these interviews you
problem you promise to be as tough on me
every time as you were the last time
really that's one I mean you were pretty
weird I didn't say you were Kathy ass
but I mean you weren't I mean I need
some teeth we're gonna do an interview I
want you to go for the jug
oh man thousand dollars but you gotta
get some way what you I want you down at
the trenches I want you down to the
gutter oh I'm always in the gutter
audience once as well it didn't matter
papa wait just to confirm did you just
say you're donating a hundred thousand
to the help campaign our foundation will
match your foundation hundred thousand
apiece as long as you and your beautiful
bride are tough on me with these
interviews last time you were soft I was
a little soft okay well well thank you
very much that's very kind that's very
generous that'll be fantastic and of
course it would be my absolute pleasure
to go as hard as possible on the pizza
God Himself here there's a fire roaring
behind you by the way can we get a peek
of that oh it's out mmm it was on but I
guess it was hot all right well so papa
let's turn it towards the are you in the
famous house Popeye in the house where
I'm in the lab I'm in my office at the
house is this the room where you
recorded Papa John's first online pizza
order a video this is so what I did it
from this room Wow I could everybody we
were not doing the internet pizza sales
on the Internet fact I almost lost my
job we spent like eight million dollars
and it didn't work out too good the
first year like I have your set of sales
they almost fired me over that finally
come on and now it's figure number 65 70
percent of our business is is it an
amazing to look back at a time when the
internet was some crazy wild uh yeah it
was a it was a crazy a wild idea of
Papa's well let's let's turn it to oh
because we were on the topic of the of
Bo and the house and last time we didn't
ask about Bo I just wanted to ask how
was he doing he's good he's big he's
pushing 60s next one six two he's a
great skier and his teaching ski skiing
out in Colorado of course I got cut
short
but you know he loved giving me hardware
to go so you know he's healthy and happy
if he's given the old man a hardware to
go right now everybody's healthy and
happy and we're doing we're doing good
but I'm concerned about Americana the
million dollars we did today it's great
I'm all for it it touches my heart
because small business is my heart and
soul but man this is a problem I mean
this we want you know on the backside of
the virus but the carnies that has done
to our economy and what it's done to the
great working men and working women of
our country is devastating and you know
I have a feeling that may and will be
just the tip of the iceberg of what
we're all going to have to do together
right two three four moles because this
could be a hard cold winter to get out
of this mess absolutely no just one
little baby win it one little hundred
thousand at a time one little mean at a
time until we get America back up on its
feet and get it going yep I'm with you
there papa now we had a fascinating
conversation with you the last time you
were here about the pizza Al stirs we
had drawn an analogy that if you were
Caesar
Richie was Brutus who stabbed you in the
back on the floor of the Senate but
Judas is the one who killed Jesus and if
he you could mount if you can melt
Brutus and Judas the two gray portrays
in literature together you would have
you would have Ritchie I think it's a
fair analogy but that's your comments
time we wish the best for Steve you know
the problem with what he did and what
the old board did is not really what
they did to me I'm fine
it's what they did to themselves and
it's what they did to the employees in
the franchisees that's the part that you
know breaks my heart but you know I
think he feels like it's still the
company can get away with it and you
know karma is a strange thing and it
came around and nobody's heard from
Ritchie in three months you know really
rich he's off the radar off the rail
here's a guy that talked 2,000 people a
day I mean the guy was
the phone and nobody's heard from you so
what does that mean you tell me I don't
know is he dead
well I don't know what that means
I hope he's doing well I mean you can
imagine going from making Victor a
number we had him at four or five six
million a year and now I makes zero so I
think he hurt himself more than he or
anybody else but that's kind of how and
look where pop is just lower I said you
and Richie just look where pop is he
still got the fireplace well you don't
want to run a restaurant company in the
middle of Corona nineteen you just don't
and you know I got off the boat this
would be of the four time and this is
just really lucky timing to get off this
thing and I'd have to deal with the
day-to-day I couldn't imagine a stand
employees to go into work and deal with
rice but sure again pizza delivery right
now is hot you know it's gonna this is
as good as it'll ever get if you're in
the pizza delivery business ever yeah
and the question is when this comes out
the other side and those sales crash and
that cheese goes with three bucks a
pound that's going to destroy the unit
economics of the franchisees and the
independent pizzerias and that's what
I'm concerned about you know the next
not the next month or two but six months
you know where's all this going to pan
out and the problem with this thing is
it's got so many tangibles that are
uncertain unpredictable for example did
you ever think of ours could do this to
the world and at the same time same time
take oil to eleven dollars a barrel see
these these tangibles better unexpected
those are going to keep popping up the
good news is I think on all fronts
Corona has been less than we thought
it'd be hopefully done flare back up we
don't have a second or third wave I do
think if that happens and maybe I'm
optimistic I think we're better prepared
for the next way we do have a lure about
this and we get too big a hurry we go
back out and wave goes back up I think
the administration the public are better
prepared the second time around I'm
hoping we are because
need to get America back on its feet has
there been any updates on your lawsuit
against the what was the name of that
agency the the laundry service and the
and Pappajohn itself what's going on
what's the updates
well the pot it's not a get with Papa
John's so they they pretty well for the
most part being quiet
the question is how much are they
involved with this I mean we know for a
fact that laundry service taped the
conversation unbeknownst to me
we know laundry service had a
relationship with forbes the head guy at
laundry summers was the guy named Jason
Stein he had a relationship with the
report Forbes reporter we know Jason
took the tape to Forbes we also know
that the they painted the false
narrative of what the tape actually said
and we know that it was all premeditated
so we know for a fact you know magnate
executives from Papa John's have left I
talked to them all they all I know
what's going on here they tell me what's
going on
we know Wasserman set this up it was
premeditated through Jason Stein we know
they leaked it to Forbes the directors
of Papa John's we know of to Mark
Shapiro and Steve Richie the knew that
Wasserman and laundry service leaked
that tape to Forbes and set me up
they're complicit the question before
the house is is the rest of the Papa
John's board passively
more aggressively complicit in the setup
to you know sabotage me and to hurt me
and pay me in that unfavorable light and
frankly in a false light so there has
there been any material update have you
been able to hear or obtain the infamous
tape um we we have the tape the tape is
property of Papa John's and Papa John's
does not want the public to hear the
tape because there's nothing in there
that's racist about the tape remember
Papa John's had a copy of the tape a
week after all this went down I didn't
have a copy of the tape till the
following year so Appa John's knew that
there was nothing on that tape that was
going to hurt me with regards to race
yet they went along with it that's what
makes me think that pop
John was complicit in the set up by
laundry service to take over the company
as I've said on Maria Bartiromo
and other shows what's unfathomable
unthinkable is that the Board of
Directors and executives at Papa John's
use race use the black community to
steal the company that's what was hard
to believe and they did and they
continue to do it
discovery starts at the end of the month
that's going to be interesting we've got
our witnesses and they got theirs and I
think discovery will be very telling hmm
other everybody's if they didn't do
anything wrong they have nothing to
worry about if they did what you and me
and the rest of America knows they did I
think they have problems well let's see
what comes out of this I I hope there's
some explanation I just can't find
anything except they wanted to they
wanted to set me up and you know defame
me so they could steal the company now
why wouldn't you want to steal the
company the company was making 155
million dollars a year in fact here's
our nine-year run and here's your one
hundred fifty five hundred and sixty
million dollars a year profit lat 18s
five million nineteen you'll see in 2020
and they'll probably do a little better
this with Ben Corona
we're still half as much money as we
made in 2011 2012 and the point is look
at the damage this board of directors
the management did to a great company
155 million dollars down to basically
nothing and they basically destroyed the
reputation of the company have something
like that what they would probably say
in response to that is that they would
say well well it was actually John
Schnatter
with the controversy with the NFL and
the public backlash that he's faced that
was responsible for the lost trust in
the brand is that not what they would
say in response to that and how would
you respond
that argument is not defensible because
both recordings NFL and laundry service
we have a tape and there's nothing
either recording that should be
indicative of anything to start up to
stir up this kind of controversy what
Papa John's realized when they wanted to
steal the company if you see you can't
still Papa John Pizza without running
the founder in the ground unless you
destroy me you can't steal the country
so they understood early on if they did
nothing if they just did nothing and let
the press and the media and social media
run and basically crucify me then that
puts them in the driver's seat to take
the company over and that's what they
did in other words they were complicit
in destroying my reputation and creating
this scandal which has hurt thousands of
employees and hundreds of franchisees
because they did nothing
they were passive aggressive and they
did nothing and they hurt the brand let
me let me go back to something you had
mentioned previously that that stood out
to me you had mentioned that Papa John
is using the black community in a way to
make their using them you said can you
expand on that
well the to play into a successful white
guy is racist is an easy sell especially
if they're coming you don't defend that
and so if they can paint the founder in
a false narrative a false light then
they can put him off to the side and
steal the company and that's what they
did
now the black leaders that I talked to
know that that they're just being used
to hurt me they know that and I think
America knows that but yet Papa John's
still is playing that up are you
referring to the fact that Shaq that
they pick Shaq to be a board member I
think Shaq's words were he's being you
know he's being used as kind of a tool
to perpetuate this thing I would hope
he's smarter than that
Ethan but you know out of the thirty
board members that the owners of Papa
John's the the Chairman has there's only
one black board they're all
basically you know old in white they
maybe there's one Latino except Shaq so
the odds of having one black board
member on the Papa John's board and use
him as a spokesperson and you've seen
the footage where he continues to
agitate the situation I think that's not
coincidental you're referring to this
video clip you sent me do you mind if I
play it papa
sure okay let me play this for our
audience just to give them a reference
like Shaq you better believe there's
gonna be haters ICO is Papa John hate
mail
he's getting some serious backlash
online especially from people of color
and to be honest it's starting to get to
what is Shaq life does he of a reality
shine I think it was a show and TNT like
Shaq life like a documentary Papa come
ask you something
have you noticed that Shaq is in every
commercial I mean really put on the TVs
and every commercial is an icy hot he's
in the general he's in he's in like
tongues he's in every commercial so so
is it possible that he's just added this
under his belt I mean he literally has
like probably 200 endorsement deals
right and Papa John just slid right
under his belt with the with Tom's and
alka-seltzer and the general and maybe
race didn't factor into it yeah I think
I think Shaq's a good choice as a
spokesperson I disagree with the way
they're using me because they don't
usually much he's not in as many ads
that's true I don't like the fact that
they're using him to keep stirring up a
false narrative on race right I think
that's I think that's doing a lot of
damage to Shaq and I think it all that
does is regurgitate and bring this
all backup which is not good for anybody
so the question before the house is why
do they keep bringing up a false
narrative but they're not complicit in
the setup and you know that's the main
our question
so Papa what what ultimately do you wish
out of this what do we want to happen
when this is all said and done
going into discovery you've got your own
company trashing you you know what what
what what is a happy end to this for you
well I think you want the best for the
franchisees you want the best for the
employees and I think to keep
researching resurfacing this is just not
healthy for anybody so you want Papa
John's to go on about their business and
be successful and I'm gonna definitely
go on about my business and be
successful and what's wrong with both
parties being successful I mean that
that's the wind wind so the I hope that
the coronavirus uptick keeps ticking and
keeps going that would that would be the
but still hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of stock so that would be
the good thing and I hope some of the
things I'm working with with other
pizzerias and wild health and charities
I hope that keeps going up and that's a
win so I like win-win so I want Papa
John's to win I want to win but if they
keep bringing this up that's a that's
not good for me and that's not good for
Papa John's that's what I call a
lose-lose so that needs to stop the
goals have them stop it
set the record straight I do want to get
to the bottom of how far up the chain
does this go does this go to the NFL
Goodell yeah you know it goes to
Washington the head of the DNC how how
far up does this go you think well maybe
it was just Richie and a few of the
board members well that doesn't make
sense because as soon as they got what
they wanted out of Richie they fired it
they fired him in bother with stock went
from 38 to 58 and he's disappeared for
three months too so they may have buried
him as well Papa John or did his issues
it is he made a comment to the
franchisees after the Board of Directors
fired and he said I have so much dirt on
the board and Jeff Smith and I could
make their life miserable
now what did he mean by that well how
much dirt does he have on Jeff Smith
or directors of Pappajohn so big a team
2.8 million to shut him up he did shut
up but now he's really shut up so I
don't know what's going on I think it's
bizarre interesting it is bizarre well
well I do want to ask you why not or
move back to charities or yeah I was
gonna I was gonna [ __ ] I was about to
shift my hours back um
pop up I know your time is limited so I
want to leave you with with a one last
question that was popular very popular
in our first interview I want I want to
know how was your dating life going papa
and now that you are single and ready to
mingle are you seeing it well with the
confinement and go over 19 there is no
time to be single isn't it it's well
it's a good time what I call level
setting it's a good time to get back to
the basics when you have something like
this happen that's kind of you know
sometimes life just is not fair if life
was fair to be boring as hell
so let's get a miniature violin and have
a pity party for Papa I mean we need to
get over it move on I mean who really
who really gives a [ __ ] frankly but it
helped it's helped me get closer to my
mom
I've gone back to Joe garrison bill my
high school
my roommates in college you just it
forces you go back to the basics to
where you started when you were broke
and just rebuild from there so I call it
level setting and we're level setting
and you know trying to be do the best I
can do with the kids and grandkids and
fitness and getting to be one thing
that's happened that's been great is the
you when you go through something like
this you get a rep you get rid of people
you should have been around you know
which is been great and then you meet a
whole nother group of people that are
really inspirational and like me yeah
yeah there's a lot of yeah the you know
and there's a big right you have a great
upside is that damn look downside we
gotta get on to him jack told me tell
you hi
that a voodoo doll Papa you stab the
needles in a person and we've agreed
with my good name and my great pizza
recipe in his personality we're gonna
we're gonna have a lot of fun so where
did that cop you are you sticking
needles in that Bank Papa yep soon as we
get through Corona we need to I don't
know if you want to call it what do you
call it a boo doo doll or a hex or spell
but the spell of Papa you know so every
time something bad happens we got
anything Oh
the spell the Papa heck we can have fun
with that but let's get through this
well we have we have yeah let's let's we
already have a hex we've already got 1x
thank you for your generosity 1 million
- to charity to small business owners
and I think I though I'm I'm not sure I
understood you still correctly you are
donating $100,000 to our charitable
cause I'm gonna match you and your
beautiful bride your 400 I'm in front as
long as when we do these interviews you
don't give me any slack is that a deal
that's a deal of course that's a deal
well Papa then just wow that's so
generous thank you so much mama wow
that's so nice
well if you're fans my best and God
bless and we'll keep fighting the good
fight here we'll get this absolutely
thank you papa for checking in we are
team papa all the way we thank you so
much for that for that donation that's
amazing merchandise yeah but don't it's
but it but but we have to talk but our
lawyers need to talk before you start
with the Papa blessing lawyers all right
Thank You papa we'll talk all right well
uh Papa is in the house it's interesting
to see him in that very room the famous
hot or beau took place that fireplace is
so epic isn't it how did it turn on
without no one touching it I think there
was there someone in it in the room with
him with a remote or something that's
pretty crazy cuz I heard him say that it
what kind of technology is that it's
Papa Tech cuz it's real fire well it's
not a digital
no I think the
I think the remote turns on the gas huh
not that it's not that crazy
okay I mean if you have Papa money
anything's possible
why that's so exciting though the
hundred thousand so now that we have an
extra hundred thousand we can do five
five winners every day that's two
hundred fifty twenty five hundred
dollars a day five winners and because
we're gonna have like a little surplus
because we've already started we're
gonna do on the final day we're just
gonna do a mega giveaway for whatever we
have leftover well that's that concludes
our podcast here today we've been gone
but it's good to be back and there's
friend and to everybody who's watching
this just to comb through everything
I've said good luck god bless its
problem sure there's a couple of nuggets
there Oh before we go I wanted to I
actually wanted to make a statement
because over the last couple weeks the
last just because we didn't do an
episode last week and then we had the
interview with dr. ding the week before
it's been a while since we had an
episode where I was participating
directly and on our last episode we deal
with goof where I was here in the studio
and I was pretending that I was at home
tending yeah well I don't know if you
guys have seen but there's been quite a
few comments sympathizing with my
situation and what guy the reason that I
really feel like I need to say something
is I've actually seen quite a few people
during this drama that was going on
defending you Ethan saying you're a good
guy because you let me sleep in this TV
not weird like what might be a good guy
for just paying you enough money to
actually write which yeah I know I
noticed that too I love that even sleep
in the studio I would by the way I don't
want to make fun of anybody I don't want
this to be negative because people that
we're sympathizing so I appreciate that
but I just want to let everybody know
I'm okay it was a tag I I have a home I
just needed to be here at the studio for
the way that we're doing the zoom call
and all the recording and
think so it was Dan's idea and
originally I was like oh yeah no I warm
on it but y'all thought it would be fun
it's a good I throw a wicked party them
oh did you say what how are you everyone
check in with me Ian what are you doing
you're looking off and it's not feeling
well are you sick
Ian oh my stomach Phil I think it's the
like Dan said the weather changing
allergy [ __ ] I don't know whose house so
hot today it's so hot
yeah it's miserable I hate that weather
whose house is that buying you oh it's
whoa I mean even though you know Dan is
homeless I'm doing very well so it's all
good is that a person's house a famous
person's house in particular yes Ian I
mean I don't know do you call me famous
yeah I see this is going nowhere
Zach tell me about yourself how you
feeling I've had quite a week actually
my dog almost died he got stung like
wait what yeah he got stung by a bee
winda anaphylactic shock we had gone to
the hospital at 10:30 at night Wow yeah
he was like passing out his gums went
pale he was born we thought we were
going Wow and yeah so that was rough
found my first gray hair even more
traumatic which yeah I don't know why
I'm getting gray hairs with a little
salt and pepper actually look for you
that's that's what people have said but
I wouldn't stress about that dude yeah
he's dressed but other than that it's
fine you know
staying home I went to the market a few
times and sack how old is your dog what
kind of is it a little dog yeah he's
three years old he's a Maltese mix oh
yeah I know I'm sorry that's I'm so
scared of one of our dogs getting stung
because they're so small it was we were
I mean I ran to the the thank God there
was a like a petty are open I ran with
my dad and I mean we were we were
bawling in the car crying because we
thought we were gonna lose him how did
you find out your dog got stung he my
brother was out walking him and he said
my dog Matisse jumped and he started
like limping on his paw and then my
brother went to look at it and there was
a stinger in there and all of a sudden
he started vomiting and Oh dogs always
react that way or hepatech he's allergic
to it just happens to be allergic to it
he's been stung by two bees before and
he's never been in anaphylactic shock
you know what happens with neighbors
that bees they get worse with every
sting yeah that's why I I've been stung
like ten times and the last time I got
stung which was very long ago I do at
the hospital there's a weird thing with
bee stings but it gets more and more
deadly going on you've been stung by
bees ten times yeah I suppose these as a
kid for some stupid reason and I got I
don't know I don't understand it but I
got stung like five times and then I got
stung accidentally a few more times
after that right like the last time well
what about the people on my weird
obsessions because there's someone who
does it for pleasure
that's your radio you're ready I agree
that once weird I guess that's a really
good question I don't know huh well I'm
glad your dog what did they do at the
vet how did they they put him they put
him on an IV the game some antibiotics
we have some antibiotics for him still
they gave us to take home but yeah he's
that was very scary he's okay now he's
okay now yeah thankfully that's good
that's great we have to protect our
animals yeah it was so scary because
like his gums went pale and but he's
happy-go-lucky he's good
everything thankfully good you know
we're monitoring where he walks now and
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] bees [ __ ] suck
why they gotta sting everything just
mind your own business bro knowns
good deal bees and ticks why do oh yeah
we keep getting ticks on our dogs it's
driving me crazy I mean they're not
deadly but they're [ __ ] disgusting
and I'm really glad that Lyme disease is
I was really worried about Lyme disease
until I learned it's mostly an East
Coast thing that's very rare out here
and in this part of the country so I'm
less worried about the Lyme disease but
I find them on one of the dogs like
every week and it's just so disgusting
yeah it's really hard to get it out
because the dogs will fight us try to
get it out and they leave these huge
welts where they remove like huge scars
it's just it's horrible anyway um I'm
sorry to hear about that Zak I'm glad
your dog is doing well you gotta watch
out for the dead bees too because they
still have the stingers [ __ ] those bees
man ian is in anything else you're doing
good you're not feeling well but you've
got a big beautiful house Dan doing
great
not home not homeless yes all righty
then that's the show we will be back
next week we've got a ton of topics to
talk about but there was just so much to
fit into this episode
stay tuned baby this is the HP podcast
we ain't going nowhere right you are
that's right we ain't going nowhere son
even if even if you know it's funny
everybody Circle Jerks about how shitty
our podcast is like of all these
commentary channels I mean people are
watching there are people watching right
now those are fake of you look I don't
like these people clearly don't even
watch I mean podcasts are by nature low
effort right I think we put I think we
we work for people assume that we don't
do any work we work pretty hard on
there's this three guys full-time
working on this podcast when we work a
lot on this show may not show
but we do you know all right thank you
guys for watching we love you we
appreciate you hop on over to Twitter
get some free money to help you in these
tough times I don't know won't get that
hundred from Papa but until then we're
still given three winners per day
it's a his s a producer I don't think he
has a producer his guy texts me good oh
he did hey let's work out the logistics
of how to do that so it's happening yeah
that's super cool all right guys we'll
see you next week we appreciate you we
love you and uh adios until next time
[Music]